[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
le sial strasbourg c'est parti pour 30
minutes de décryptage de l'actualité
européenne
quelques jours après l'audition tant
attendu de mark zuckerberg devant les
parlementaires européens focus sur les
faits qui nous alors qu'en france une
proposition de loi a été déposée sur le
sujet comment lutter contre la
propagation de fausses nouvelles et les
manipulations sur les réseaux sociaux
reportages et débats à suivre mais
d'abord l'actualité l'italie dans
l'impasse le président serge vieux
matériel a refusé l'investiture d'un
ministre de l'économie ouvertement
europhobe proposé par le premier
ministre désigné tous étaient comptés
qui échoue donc amené la coalition
cinque télé et ligue au pouvoir le
président de la république donc va
convoquer de nouvelles élections et
entre temps à nommer un premier ministre
technique
une décision qui a fait bondir les deux
leaders on écoute
nous devons amener cette crise à
l'intérieur du parlement ce qui signifie
avoir recours à l'article 90 de la
constitution sur la responsabilité du
président et c'est au sein du parlement
que nous devons en débattre ensuite le
parlement décidera mais gardez à
l'esprit que nous conjointement avec la
ligue possédons la majorité
parlementaire
ils doivent nous dire si le gouvernement
est déterminé par l'écart entre les taux
d'emprunt à bruxelles berlin et paris
nous ne nous résignons pas nous
n'abandonnons pas nous serons plus forts
et plus déterminés qu'auparavant soit
les règles européennes change soient
restés dans cette union européenne n'a
plus de sens dans notre programme
n'était pas question de sortir de l'euro
ou de l'europe pas de bréxent dit rien
nous avions seulement pour projet de
changer les règles européennes au
bénéfice des italiens selon moi le plus
grave c'est que le président de la
république a choisi les marchés les
règles européennes au détriment du vote
des italiens
et ça c'est sérieux et pour commenter
donc ce psychodrame cette presque ce
reality show à l'italienne c'est edouard
martin que j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
vous êtes député européen socialiste
bonjour bienvenue toujours est ce que
justement on entendait à l'instant
matteo salvini le leader de la ligue
est ce que ce n'est pas une trahison du
vote des italiens ce qui est en train de
se dérouler ce que je constate c'est la
troïka qui pointe le bout de son nez
quoi
la troïka bce et commission rappelle
exactement où c'est effectivement ce
sont ces institutions si on en croit ce
qui se passe en tout cas c'est le
message qui est perçu par les italiens
c'est le monde de institutionnel le
monde de la finance qui doit déterminer
le vote des italiens donc non respect de
la démocratie
on peut ne pas aimer ça ne fait pas
plaisir moi ce vote italien en tant que
démocrate je me dis à l'italie par sur
des nouveaux chemins ça ça risque de
tanguer y compris pour nous mais bon je
suis un démocrate je respecte la voix du
peuple italien et donc là le message qui
est envoyé
c'est dire aux italiens vous avez mal
voter c'est nous qui allons vous
apprendre comment voter on va vous
imposer un autre vote c'est quand même
je veux dire en terme de messages c'est
terrible les dégâts que ça peut est ce
qu'il faut dans ce cas là comme du coup
di maio le leader en fait des cinque
terre et le demande destituer le
président matin et là je me garderai
bien de dire ce que j'y tiens tu dois
faire mais effectivement il faut user
utiliser l'ensemble des textes existants
en italie la constitution et natar et la
refusant le poste de premier ministre
mais ce comté parce que il aurait une
politique irait au contraire des
intérêts européens
c'est terrible comme image et en plus
nommer un ministre à technicien un
ancien du fmi
je dire en termes de communication et
d'image que reçoivent les italiens en
pleine figure
on fait pas mieux pour faire exploser un
pays je veux dire c'est est ce que ces
gens là sont conscients puisqu'ils ont
provoqué voilà j'ai prévenu qu'il
faudrait attendre l'acteur vous en
faites à ce que ce soit bien pire une
fois que les italiens reviendront aux
urnes
moi je le crains je deviens très
fortement que les italiens vexé fâché et
on peut comprendre cette colère des
italiens sanctionne encore plus durement
7 pouces 17 posture du président italien
et fasse que salvini soit renforcée
alors il ya aussi les sorties de la part
à la fois des manuels macro qui a salué
le geste de sergio matar est là qui a
donc recommencé le sulfureux pas du
ministre donc de l'économie qui est
ouvertement europhobe guenther oettinger
le commissaire au budget
lui a fait savoir dans une interview à
la deutsch vélo donc une radio allemande
de manière un petit peu
voilà plus nuancé tout du moins que
finalement en fait les marchés à
apprendre aux italiens comment voter
est-ce que là aussi du côté des
capitales et du côté de bruxelles en
fait on joue pas un peu au pompier
pyromane on joue sur les peurs
emmanuel macron qui vient de son petit
coupé de son petit commentaire je ne
sais pas comment il aurait réagi
si un pays autre aurait commenté c'est
la nomination de ses ministres je viens
pas commencent les autres pays de colons
que pensent les autres pays de et douars
philippe enfin bref je veux dire ça
c'est de notre compétence et personne
n'a à la commenter
il faut réformer cette europe il faut
réformer cette europe l'europe des
citoyens aujourd'hui la réponse que
l'europe la porte c'est je tourne moi en
tant qu'institution le dos aux citoyens
italiens et c'est pas comme ça qu'on
pense que l'europe
alors il ya autre chose sur un autre
dossier sur lequel l'europe est très
attendu c'est la question de l'acier et
de l'aluminium et donc de la guerre
commerciale potentiel avec les états
unis donc c'est un peu donald trump et
l'union européenne
acte iii scène 4 et une nouvelle fois
les italiens seront les européens bardon
sont suspendus à la décision du
président américain sur ces questions en
écoute aujourd'hui je m'apprête à
défendre la sécurité nationale
américaine
en instaurant des droits de douane sur
les importations d'acier et d'aluminium
nous aurons un tarif douanier de 25% sur
l'a6 étrangers et un tarif douanier de
10% sur l'aluminium étrangers voilà donc
c'était le 8 mars dernier et dans martha
ce que vous direz que l'europe a
capitulé face aux desiderata de donald
trump
là pour le coup si on fait à part les
lacs la situation italienne jus aimé que
les astuces européenne la commission le
conseil et une position aussi ferme face
aux décisions de donald trump qui bafoue
toutes les règles internationales du
commerce
en même temps je le dis depuis le départ
le message qu'envoie donald trump à la
mondialisation de l'économie mérite
d'être entendu pourquoi dans le trompe
on arrive à prendre ce genre de décision
ces quinze ans de désinvestissement aux
états unis notamment deux secteurs
majeurs l'acier l'aluminium qui font
qu'aujourd'hui c'est ces grandes
entreprises américaines sont quasiment à
l'agonie ne sont plus compétitives
collectivement ni qualitativement et
donc pour protéger son industrie et pour
financer les investissements nécessaires
pour qu'elles soient de nouveau
compétitive et bien il fait payer ça aux
autres donc aux importations
donc c'est contraire à toutes les règles
mais il faut qu'on tire la leçon parce
que nous souffrons aussi d'un manque
d'investissements au niveau de l'union
européenne et il faudrait faire
attention de ne pas tomber de la même
situation d'ici 5 10 ans où on soit dans
un secteur industriel complètement à
l'agonie
ceci étant dit on dit lorsque l'union
européenne dijon va saisir
l'om c'est pour essayer de régler ces
différends au sein de l'om c'est jeudi
que là pour le coup c'est la poudre de
perlimpinpin l'om ça ne fonctionne pas
ne fonctionnent plus les états unis ça
fait les refuse donald trump refuse
d'envoyer des juges des tribunaux
d'arbitrage de l'om c est donc qui
vaille est l'institution de toute façon
qui ne fonctionnent plus donc c'est pas
elle qui réglera la question n'est plus
au top ça veut dire qu'il faut que
l'union européenne rentre finalement
dans cette guerre commerciale et que si
donald trump met en place en fait don
des taxes supplémentaires sur l'acier
sur l'aluminium européen
il faut qu'on puisse y répondre il faut
qu'on puisse répondre à la surcapacité
mondiale de production d'acier et
l'aluminium qui émane de ou
essentiellement de la chine sauf si vous
regardez bien nous autres européens on
n'ose pas trop aller titiller des
chinois parce qu'on a beaucoup d'intérêt
économique en chine
donc faut surtout pas et ça fait 15 ans
que la chine nous promet à nous
européens que effectivement elle allait
fermer des capacités de production parce
que ça déstabilise complet ce n'est pas
le cas et ça n'est pas le cas et donc un
moment donné de toute façon si on règle
pas ce problème là maintenant ça va nous
exploser en pleine figure en coupe de
vols et nous allons être les grands
perdants parce que vous avez vu qu'il ya
un accord qui encourt entre les chinois
allaient les états unis et nous les
européens nous sommes les spectateurs de
tout ça justement à ce propos je
rappelle quelques tweets 1 du président
américain
nous devons protéger notre pays et nos
travailleurs notre industrie de
l'aluminium est en mauvaise posture si
vous n'avez pas d'acier vous n'avez pas
de pays est le deuxième il y aura de
grandes nouvelles à venir pour les
merveilleux travailleurs américains de
l'industrie automobile après de
nombreuses décennies durant lesquelles
vous avez perdu vos emplois au profit
d'autres pays
vous avez assez attendu finalement pour
être complètement clair pour nos
téléspectateurs edouard martin est-ce
qu'il s'attaquerait pas un petit peu à
l'alma
donald trump parce que l'europe n'est
pas en train de payer pour les
exportations allemandes
que ce soit sur l'acier ou l'automobile
effectivement l'europe est impacté mais
en réalité si on regarde à la loupe
c'est surtout l'allemagne qui exporte de
la cie qui exporte des voitures même si
il ya des usines allemandes implantées
aux états unis qui produisent aux états
unis et qui exporte aussi vers d'autres
pays la question à laquelle trump ne
répond pas c'est que va-t-il y compris
taxer les entreprises allemandes
importés sur le territoire américain
donc mais ça pose un vrai problème de
déséquilibre effectivement lorsqu'un
pays et on dire en sueur dominance sur
un marché quel qu'il soit
ben le risque c'est d'avoir des trump à
la tête d'un pays qui dit stop ça suffit
ça suffit
ce déséquilibre de la balance
commerciale et n'est plus supportable
pour le citoyen et il avait déjà attaqué
en gala merkel justement dans la
campagne de non financières américaines
qui prennent des mesures
protectionnistes qui va amener va nous
amener dans une situation d'instabilité
assez féroce et dans une guerre
commerciale dont dans tout le monde va
sortir perdants et comment on protège du
coup les emplois en europe face à cette
guerre commerciale simplement en ayant
des textes qui s'applique à tous de la
même façon au niveau européen nous avons
des textes assez assez ferme même très
ferme sur la concurrence déloyale
eh bien je trouve qu'on est peut-être un
peu trop permissif et si à chaque fois
qu'on essaie de titiller un peu la chine
pas pour les titiller mais pour dire
'attendez nos règles de défense
commerciale ne sont peut-être pas
suffisamment armé vous voyez toujours
qu'à chaque fois souvent et je veux pas
faire de l'anti allemagne mais c'est
souvent les amants qui disent hop on
touche pas à jeun pourquoi est ce que
jean désintérêt beaucoup plus fort que
d'autres
il faut rééquilibrer tout ça et se poser
la question sur quel est l'intérêt de
l'europe que nous voulons construire si
l'intérêt de l'europe c'est l'addition
des intérêts particuliers on va contre
un mur alors il ya un autre dossier
justement qui est assez révélateur de
l'addition de ces intérêts particuliers
c'est la question du congé parental
un débat qui fait rage en ce moment ici
au parlement
la france avec 13 autres pays s'opposent
à cette proposition et emmanuel macron
répondait ici au parlement à strasbourg
le 17 avril dernier
en écoute
sur les propositions qui sont faites et
le projet de directive j'en approuve
totalement le principe mais les congés
parentaux pays au niveau de l'indemnité
maladie journalières c'est une belle
idée qui peut coûter très cher et finir
par être insoutenable les modalités
ainsi décrite tels que elles sont
analysées sur le système français ont un
coût qui est potentiellement explosif
alors on parle d'un surcoût edouard
martin de 1,6 milliard d'euros l'idée
donc c'est d'avoir un congé parental de
quatre mois pour chaque parent non
cessibles notre non transférable qui
pourraient être pris de manière
fractionnée aussi en temps partiel jusqu
au 12 ans l'enfant donc c'est quand même
hyper ambitieux solides et on part sur
1,6 milliard d'euros de surcoût est-ce
que c'est pas un finançable est ce que
vous n'avez pas été trop loin
cette belle idée et je veux essayer de
détricoter le message du président
depuis que parce que il n'y voit ça
comme uniquement et un coup alors qu'en
réalité c'est un investissement l'idée
qu'elle est l'idée défendue derrière ça
c'est que l'éducation de l'enfant n'est
pas exclusivement réservé à la femme à
la mer je veux le père ou s'il doit y
prendre sa part et doit contribuer aussi
à l'éducation de l'enfant d'ailleurs
c'est ce que les perches veulent
premièrement deuxièmement y compris sur
la langue économique l'ensemble des
patrons européens et français disque
effectivement cette possibilité de
faciliter l'accès au marché du travail
des femmes et est une plus-value pour
l'économie française donc il n'a pris
que la case dépenses n'a pas pris là le
retour entre guillemets sur
investissement parce que pour moi c'est
un investissement
mais c'est surtout l'idée de dire
comment voulez vous redonner confiance
aux citoyens envers l'europe
si à chaque fois que nous essayons de
faire des avancées sociales contre cette
fameuse europe sociale nous avons des
présidents paraît-il du nouveau monde
qui essaie de les contraindre
comment qualifiez-vous du coup la
position française dogmatique dogmatique
et moi j'étais très vexé très fâché
déçu d'entendre de la part de la
commission européenne c'est dire
attendez mais vous voulez vous prenez
l'europe sociale
mais c'est la france votre pays qui a
pris la tête de la fronde pour fédérer
une minorité bien quand même très ce
pays qui bloque dont l'allemagne
alors évidemment aujourd'hui la france
parce qu'il ya eu quand même campagne
médiatique assez forte en pointant les
aigles les incohérences de ce
gouvernement là donc ils font un peu
marche arrière que parce que pour être
clair pour le téléspectateur on a tous
signé donc les pays ont signé à göteborg
il y a quelques mois depuis les sherlock
européen des droits sociaux en disant
qu'il fallait tous converger et aller
vers une forme d'harmonie des droits
sociaux et là effectivement quelques
mois plus tard on a lens est l'antre de
cette nature de passage que certains
latrace déjà alors rapidement on se
souvient tous 1 en 2015
le congé maternité où il y avait eu
aussi une ambition de le réformer
une volonté en fait de le passer à
plusieurs semaines finalement il avait
été totalement retoqué est ce que le
risque en fait si on ne trouve pas un
consensus c'est qui se passe la même
chose pour ce congé parental alors pour
l'instant moi je tiens à saluer quand
même la présidence bulgare elle continue
et normalement ce texte là devrait être
votée le 11 juillet la commission emploi
j'ose espérer que le conseil ne va pas
fermer complètement la porte parce que
sinon ça risque d'être du même tonneau
et que cet accord là ce projet là soient
classés verticalement bon bah écoutez
rendez vous donc en juillet merci et de
l'art merci à vous de nous avoir
expliqué tous à l'art on continue
campagne présidentielle en france aux
états unisbre exceed depuis quelques
mois aucune échéance électorale n'était
pas renié par les soupçons de
manipulation de fait news la france
discutent en ce moment même d'une
proposition loi c'est un reportage de
fabien becker et 2,0 me rabier
[Musique]
dans des organes de presse répandent des
contrevérités infamante ce ne sont plus
des journalistes ce sont des organes
l'influencent rhj est une déesse pique
nique ont été des organes influence
durant cette campagne qui ont à
plusieurs reprises produit des
contre-vérités sur ma personne et ma
campagne
c'était à versailles il y a un an
emmanuel macron régler ouvertement ses
comptes avec deux médias qui l'accusé
d'avoir relayé défèque news pendant la
campagne présidentielle un an plus tard
une proposition de loi contre les post
nouvelle arrive au parlement douze
convives
bienvenue chez arte france financé à
100% par le kremlin avec la chaîne
défend le point de vue de la russie sur
l'actualité mais récuse les accusations
de fait news depuis son lancement en
décembre dernier rt est étroitement
surveillée par le csa qui verrait ses
pouvoirs étendus par la nouvelle loi
demain le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel pourrait même suspendre le
conventionnement de l'achète csa est une
autorité administrative c'est pas une
autorité indépendante donc déjà c'est un
premier problème de confier ça à une
autorité qui dépend finalement de l'état
et puis pour le reste une loi qui serait
faite sur mesure pour rt ce serait une
loi entre guillemets quasi à 2000m et ça
ce serait pas constitutionnel donc on
vérifiera si le droit est bel et bien
respecté mais on peut pas faire une loi
contre une chaîne ou alors c'est
simplement qu'on veut un petit peu
contrôler l'information et ça ce serait
dommage c'est sans doute pour ça que le
syndicat national des journalistes parle
de censure et toute la profession
dénonce plus globalement une loi qui
porte en elle des dérives de contrôle de
l'information
sous le feu des critiques la procédure
d'urgence pour stopper la diffusion
d'une fausse information
en période électorale un juge aurait
alors 48 heures pour déterminer si une
information est fausse
le texte exige aussi plus de
transparence de la part des plateformes
numériques
selon reporters sans frontières si
l'intention est bonne elle comporte
néanmoins un risque
ça n'est ni les états ni les plates
formes qui sont légitimes et dans les
deux classes il le faisait ce serait
dangereux à distinguer le bon grain de
l'ivraie à dire ce qui relève du
journalisme honnête de ce qui relève de
la rumeur ou de l'information
malveillantes
pour rsf c'est donc aux journalistes
eux-mêmes de valoriser les bonnes
pratiques
mais pour un collège d'experts
missionnés par la commission européenne
cela doit s'accompagner d'une éducation
aux médias à l'ère des trolls alors moi
évidemment je pousse l'air dé les elfes
as à dire que ce que je dis c'est il
faut mobiliser la population il faut lui
montrer lui expliquer justement les
différentes formes de techno 1 c'est un
processus éducatif l'éducation mediaset
une forme d'autorégulation
c'est sans doute le meilleur film alors
même exercice que tout à l'heure vous
avez juste m'expliquer voilà ce que vous
avez compris ce que vous voyez qui
intéresse
et chacun à leur avis mais
c'est pas qui a raison qui a tort
très bonne question qu'est ce que ça
change que ce monsieur soit payé cent
cinquante mille euros par total qui soit
pas du tout n'est pas rose il n'a pas
être objective par la magie d'accord les
s'éduquer plutôt que légiférer et dans
ce collège de vichy 24 élèves de 4e
développent leur esprit critique
si vous êtes une génération en fait vous
allez avoir une information et cette
information vous la gardez pas pour vous
aider à transmettre et c'est important
tout le temps que vous la vérifier
12 quand on discute avec les élèves et
compare les réseaux sociaux tout de
suite après ils vous disent voilà moi je
regarde le journal télévisé
mais j'ai rien à en dire sauf que le
journal télévisé aussi la formation se
fabrique
lorsque vous avez des journaux télévisés
qui accumule par exemple au moment des
grèves six ou sept sujets sur le
mécontentement des usagers
bon bah ça c'est un choix éditorial
c'est une lyre archi de l'information et
ça produit une certaine forme
d'information c'est important aussi
d'avoir une certaine distance critique
en jeu recréer de la confiance entre
producteurs et consommateurs de
l'information
d'après le baromètre annuel du journal
la croix sur la confiance dans les
médias
deux français sur trois doutent de
l'indépendance des journalistes
[Musique]
alors comment lutter contre l'effet que
news pour en débattre j'ai plaisir de
recevoir virginie rosières vous êtes
députée européenne socialiste membre du
groupe socialiste au parlement vous êtes
par erreur par ailleurs rapporteur de la
directive sur les lanceurs d'alert
bienvenus jean marie cavada vous êtes
député européen membre du groupe a d e
et vous êtes par ailleurs donc ancien
journaliste on s'en souvient tous
peut-être virginie rosières est ce que
vous direz que c'était la loi de fixer
ce qui est le cas le vrai du faux
non certainement pas de fixer ce qui est
le vrai du faux par contre d'établir
clairement les responsabilités
aujourd'hui diffusé des fausses
informations éventuellement calomnier
des gens ce n'est pas quelque chose de
légal et ça ouvre la voie possiblement
des poursuites et des condamnations
simplement on a des acteurs aujourd'hui
qui échappent à cette responsabilité là
c'est les plateformes qui se positionne
sur un rôle d'intermédiaire mais ça a
été dit viseur et pas d'autres
producteurs d'information oui mais en
même temps on a une éditorialiste à sion
c'est pour ça qu'on voit d'ailleurs
typiquement les fausses informations
parce qu'elle elle crée de l'audience
parce qu'un jour le côté spectaculaire
être largement diffusé parce qu'elle
rapporte elle rapporte beaucoup
d'audience et donc beaucoup de retombées
économiques sont pas de véritables
dentelles noires éditorialisation ainsi
quand même
mais est ce que jean marie cavada c'est
la loi qui réussira en fait à faire en
sorte que les plateformes se mettront un
pompier présent je crois que la question
se pose à deux niveaux combien de dire
virginie la loi doit fixer le cadre des
responsabilités et puis il ya un
deuxième niveau
le deuxième niveau c'est celui je dirais
des de ceux dont c'est vraiment le
métier c'est à dire l'univers des
journalistes qui doit lui même faire le
ménage dans ce qu'ils diffusent dans ce
dont il a la responsabilité
et puis à l'intérieur de ça il ya
quelque chose qui ne se fait pas bien et
que l'europe d'ailleurs n'a pas réussi
encore à imposer bien que nous soyons
vraiment sur le chemin de cette affaire
c'est-à-dire exiger des plates formes
qu'elles nettoient leurs réseaux ip et
moi j'ai toujours dit que ces réseaux
ils ont trois responsabilités la
responsabilité de payer les auteurs des
textes qu'ils prennent pour faire leur
commerce la responsabilité de sécuriser
le réseau précisément et d'employer des
gens pour ça et avec des bilans qui
l'ont ils peuvent employer 1000 2000
3000 5000 personnes on va pas pleurer
et l'autre responsabilités et les
fiscale donc la loi comme cadres et les
acteurs professionnels à l'intérieur
j'entends pour autant il ya des
puissances qu'on dit déstabilisatrices
après tout est ce que ce n'est pas une
forme de censure que de ne pas entendre
en fait le point de vue de la russie de
la chine les etats unis sur une
thématique internationale c'est vrai
qu'on focalise sur la russie mais à des
chaînes détenus par des états et qui
font un travail d' influence c'est pas
la première
on voit encore pendantes réveiller les
siens pour le qatar on a aussi la
déchaîneront qui sont le suivi par par
différentes une par des fonds publics
donc on sait que c'est un outil
d'influencé mais là de toute façon les
différents médias sont des outils aussi
d' influence ils sont porteurs d'un
message la neutralité en matière
d'information n'existe pas simplement
c'est la transparence qui doit prévaloir
savoir qui parle et d'où parle
les personnes qui émettent le message et
ça c'est effectivement cette obligation
de transparence et elle est nécessaire
mais comme je disais comme le disait
jean da mais on a aussi besoin d'avoir
quand même c'est là où se pose la
question des moyens d'action rapide y
compris dans la diffusion numérique
aujourd'hui la diffusion d'informations
particulièrement dans l'électorat est
très encadrée on peut obtenir justement
le relais c'est là qu'on a accès à des
formations et les plateformes mais ça
n'est pas encore le cas dans l'univers
numérique en général plateforme ou autre
et c'est vrai que là dessus il ya
peut-être effectivement moi je refuse
cette question de voir les choses que
vous reflétez avec travers votre propre
question il ne s'agit pas de censure et
il s'agit de se protéger contre des
moyens de déstabilisation venus de
l'extérieur
je met dans le même sac et la même
farine le financement par la russie d'un
parti française qui est arrivée sous
forme d'emprunt le fondation dans
l'oeuvre originelle et d'autre part la
fabrication de fox news que ce soit sur
le sol français ou à partir du sol
aujourd'hui et russes demain turc après
une main chinois je ne sais quoi c'est
un moyen d'action extérieure c'est pas
une question d'opinion d'un pays enfin
il faut comme saint trivier de la
qualification un peu réflexe de fait
knut fausse information parce qu'on sait
aussi qu'on a de nombreux sujets sur
lesquels ce qui peut apparaître au début
comme une information en tout cas
contraire aux vérités communément nice
finalement se révèle être la vérité et
il ya parfois besoin sur vous savez que
je suis mobilisé sur les lanceurs
d'alerté mais un lanceur d alerte au
début quand tu va révéler quelque chose
il va aller contre les idées communément
reçu et on va très vite
l'incriminé au départ on peut le
qualifier de la même manière générale on
a besoin d'une presse indépendante d'une
presse forte protection du recyclage de
ces déchets des jambes et donc c'est
pour ça que effectivement on doit
pouvoir intervenir rapidement des
périodes précises mais la détermination
de la vérité elle doit suivre son cours
et on ne doit pouvoir caractérisé a
priori une information qu'on aimerait
vous faut simplement parce qu'elle
dérange ou qu'elle vient bousculer un
certain nombre de vérités communément
admise alors vous savez que mark
zuckerberg a été auditionné ici au
parlement européen par les
parlementaires il s'est de nouveau
excusé un des manquements de la
plateforme et il a donné quelques pistes
d'amélioration en écoute en 2016
nous avons été trop lents à identifier
les interférences russe sur notre
plateforme qui ont influencé des
élections américaines
nous avons davantage mis l'accent sur
des cyber-attaques suis traditionnels
tels que par exemple le phishing ou des
malwares et nous avons informé les
citoyens nous n'étions pas suffisamment
prêts et préparés à une campagne de
désinformation préparer tel que nous
l'avons découverte depuis lors oui mais
ça vous fait les investissements
significatifs pour protéger l'intégrité
du processus électoral en rendant ce
type d'attaqué pour bénéficier de la xix
sur notre plateforme
alors il a été auditionné on se souvient
à la suite en fait du scandale cambridge
analytica donc cette plateforme qui a
aspiré les données en fait deux millions
de personnes pour manipuler en fait
l'opinion à la fois aux états unis mais
également potentiellement fait dans le
cadre du brics it
à l'heure où on parle d'échec news est
ce que on va légiférer potentiellement
sur cette question de cette news mais ce
qu'on n'ait pas déjà passer à l'étape
supérieure jean marie cavada
d'abord il faut mettre les choses dans
l'ordre
moi j'ai toujours considéré et défendue
ici au parlement notamment l'idée que
les réseaux les plateformes
c'est un média avec nous toute la
responsabilité que des médias ordinaire
les vôtres on est par conséquent toutes
les obligations de contrôle de
vérification des excuses car on s'est
trompé pour ne pas tromper le spectateur
le où le lecteur de du réseau ils ont
une responsabilité éditoriale contrôler
le bien entendu et je n'en démord pas et
sinon les sanctions de la loi des pays
n'avait qu'une instance
meeting avec une responsable organe de
presse est responsable des informations
qu'il ya un directeur de public et donc
il s'agit pas on lorsqu'on parle de
cette censure dont il s'agit simplement
d'être responsable de ce conte de ce
qu'on publie d'avoir conscience de ce
qu'on fait beaucoup d merci à vous le
checkpoint se penche cette semaine sur
l'autre ami le loup enfin amis pas pour
tous semble-t-il kevin dayraut fait le
point le checkpoint s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
la france doit-elle créer une espèce
protégée elle décime les troupeaux le
gouvernement permettra d'en tuer 40 par
an mais la contestation gronde et le
ministre de l'agriculture de déclaré un
éleveur qui est attaquée à la capacité
de se défendre
il ya plus qu au delà du gotha vous
pouvez vous défendre la france peut-elle
envoyer paître l'europe grâce à des
conditions favorables et des mesures de
protection stricte
le loup a fait son retour en europe
italie d'où viennent du spécimen
français espagne allemagne suisse en
france de 30 et une zone de présence
permanente en 2013 on est passé au
double en 2017 360 individus pile poil
il en vient même à rodez du côté des
frontières dire j'ai rencontré des loups
mécanisme le poussait brasse plus de
11000 trois tués l'an dernier
essentiellement des eaux va panique dont
dans les bergeries le gouvernement via
un plan a décidé de ménager la chèvre et
100 pages pour conjuguer protection de
l'espèce et en même temps à gros
pastoralisme car ce n'est pas l'église
au milieu du village
enfin peut-être l'éleveur au milieu de
la montagne ça va mieux en le disant
ce plan propose en abattre 40 par an
maxi pour certains ce n'est pas assez et
même josé bové le gilou terre est
inquiète l'europe ne l'entend pas de
cette oreille
la france en été ratifié les textes
contraignants pour la protection de la
bête mais des dérogations sont possibles
soit si l'espèce est dans un état de
conservation favorable si d'autres
solutions ne peuvent être trouvées
utiliser pleinement justifiée mais ça ne
tient pas pourquoi une population viable
c'est dix fois plus animaux il existe
bien des solutions non létales tous les
loups ne sont pas de sauvages
psychopathe et de plus les autorités à
dennis bien les berges et donc la
déclaration du ministre travers il ya
plus d'un an au delà du quota vous
pouvez vous défendre
sous-entendu tuer le lit
l'europe avec ses règles très strictes
pour l avaler de travers c'est donc
contestable
voilà donc pour le loup est donc c'est
la fin de cette émission merci à vous
d'y avoir participé et on se quitte sur
ces images magnifiques des irlandaises
et des irlandais qui fêtent la victoire
massive du oui au référendum sur
l'avortement très bonne semaine à tous
ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]